how do you define strength strength to
me honestly is defined by a guy like
Derek Lewis this man fall from the pits
of hell to build himself back up to this
point yeah to me that strength who's
that there on your TV DC it's still a
horrible nickname I maintain but you can
follow him of course DC underscore MMA
he is fighting against Derrick Lewis
whose nickname I'm not allowed to say as
a what no I'm not do you think that's
just a gay okay well for Daniel Cormier
for people very thanks for being back
sir thank you for having me again man I
appreciate it yeah especially after you
stiffed us the last time if you were not
the baddest man in the planet I would be
upset
you could be upset but instead of
Crowder confront it would be Cormier
confronts Crowder yeah it'd be more like
corny beats Crowder's ass has it curled
up in the fetal position no you don't
mind is IDIA logically confronting and
yours is you know you beat people up so
you have a career foot in broadcasting
are you hanging up the gloves still
March are you is that is that set in
stone yeah the day that's no the same
I'm not I'm looking to fight this time
and then hopefully fight brock lesnar
become in the next year and then that'll
probably be it I mean I just don't want
to be that guy that goes off on his back
man we've seen so many of our great
champions that had all these shining
examples these moments that are etched
in our minds forever but they stay too
long in my time it's over they're
getting beat by people they never would
have gotten beat before so um it's I
don't want to be that guy I wanna I want
to leave people with the memories that
IIIi have had up to this point
Brighton let me guess you see you were
really tense at one point in your career
I think kind of in that that period
where you've talked about how you really
feel you had something to prove and you
really didn't like John Jones then you
couldn't get back at him because all the
drug controversies we seem to see you're
relaxed really happy Daniel Cormier Lee
I know you're generally a are seen as an
affable guy but today it's noticeable
let me ask you is is there some kind of
a corner you've turned or just because
you keep winning like do you think you
can maintain this Dimitar and this
calmness if you were to lose or do you
think it's just
victory makes you so no is just who I am
and also Steve me not having to cut all
the weight I know I'm sure it helps but
you do seem much more relaxed to
rephrase it but you seem not always then
what was that oh wait it's not cutting
all the weight you don't fight nothing
heavy weight now so I'm not losing 45
pounds to get to the fight you know I
mean and also just really being content
with everything that I've accomplished
in this sport I mean win or lose this
weekend which I won't you can't take
away what happened in July right those
images of me with two belts will always
remain the same that's true and I think
there's a comfort in that there's a
comfort in the accomplishment and I know
that even though I'm comfortable in the
accomplishment I'm not ready to let it
go but I am Who I am and that'll never
change people can't take anything away
from me anymore
final question obviously the fight I
want to make sure the black base Derek
Lewis it is happening November second
UFC 230 let me ask you this we were
talking about rumors what I say did I
say second sorry my second that's Friday
Friday the second started wins the third
is the actual fight from Madison Square
Garden I am terrible with numbers fights
are always Saturday unless I think
sometimes if there are different
countries time zones let's not get to
this it's November third UFC 232 Daniel
Cormier best fighter in the face of the
planet right now before you leave how do
you define strength what do you think
matters most particularly for a lot of
young men listening
I like the mental you know honestly man
and and I think and this might be like
Oh we'd only hear this about fight
promotion but I think strength to me
honestly is defined by a guy like Derek
Lewis you know when Derrick Rose was a
team he left Louisiana down to Texas and
got in a ton of trouble ended up in
prison now you know that when you go to
prison there are guys in there every
night saying what they're gonna do when
they get out and how they're gonna be
better when they get out and they'll
never go back and I'm gonna make a life
for my family and they write these notes
and they do all these things as to how
life is going to improve but then they
end up back in prison pursuit of them
right right right yeah recidivism rate
is through the roof Derrick Lewis never
went back Derrick Lewis became a
millionaire
dereck loose is fighting for the
heavyweight championship of the world
that's why when people say oh you
knocked that guy out with ten seconds
I'm like ten seconds that that doesn't
surprise me because this man fall from
the pits of hell to build himself back
up to this point yeah to me that
strength right when you are dealt with
unbelievable adversity and in the face
of that adversity you don't crumble you
try to build back when I lost my
daughter and life tried to knock me down
and put me out for the count I tried to
rebuild myself when a person goes
through these terrible tragedies that
are going on today the families of these
people that are dying in these mass
shootings are dying when someone decides
to drive their car into a crowd of
people these families that scrape
themselves off the ground and rebuild
that strength you know when you're dealt
unbelievable adversity and you come
through it and become better for it that
is what the fine strength to me it's not
about lifting something up it's not
about when everything is going good your
ear to champion and everything it's
about when stuff gets bad how do you
change it that's why that's what I feel
strength is and that's why I respect the
guy that are fighting on Saturday well I
think it's a very gracious answer I
think it's very accurate of the black
piece but I would add one to accomplish
I will give you a pat in the back I also
think equally as important is when
someone does have great power it doesn't
mean there is an adversary but when
someone has made it through the
adversity how they wield that what they
do is that you've been a class act as a
champion and that means a lot as well
that fight is happening November 2nd a
third I was I just say second don't say
second dose a second and I said like
this video watch another one of our
videos or subscribe it's a notification
bell those don't really mean anything
anymore today in YouTube I would say hit
a like was a thumbs up but that might be
gone or comment below but that most
likely will be censored so bookmark the
page of course if you're using Google
Chrome they'll find a way to [ __ ] with
your bookmark so just join up at Lara's
credit comm slash mug Club that's a lot
of those credit comm slash mug Club you
get a hand at schmuck and you get access
to the fall daily one-hour show and
you're not beholden to Susan Wojcicki
slash Clint Howard